[Applaudissements]
la forme la couleur bleu électrique
c'est vraiment ça c'est vraiment ça la
voix donc oui parce qu'à la télé je
pensais que c'est ma télé qui et puis
c'est quoi sa voix c'est un mélange de
maitre gims et stéphane bern et parts de
marché oui qu'est ce que voulait
savourer cette chanson de battre guide
bah oui ça paie comme jamais les images
sont hélas allez-y on ferme la porte à
la gestapo attention j'ai payé mes
impôts
[Applaudissements]
les boutons et une honte une honte a dit
balla lô deschanel mais la belle a poco
libyen on appelle à voter ou non mais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
venant de beige et un problème
j'arrive pas à retenir les paroles des
chansons des toons ont de belles répond
des tonneaux de bella elle s'est mise à
l'honneur
[Applaudissements]
tous les
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors que faire